from the belching power stations of
China to the burning forests of Brazil
more greenhouse gases than ever are
being added to the air we breathe new
research by the United Nations
Environment Program shows emissions are
climbing and the world is lacking the
collective political will to do anything
about it
only by cutting emissions by 7% every
year for the next decade does the planet
stand any reasonable chance of limiting
global warming to 1.5 degrees and
averting a climate breakdown is that
possible absolutely will it take
political will yes will we need to have
the private sector lean in yes but the
science tells us that we can do this
greenhouse gas emissions reached a
record high in 2018 of 53 billion tons
even if countries come good on current
pledges to reduce them that only level
off in 2030 pushing up the global
temperature by more than three degrees
to prevent a climate breakdown warming
needs to be held below one and a half
degrees that will mean more than having
emissions by 32 billion tonnes in just a
decade a gap between what we are doing
and what we need to doing is growing
wider so we were already not doing
enough and the challenge is getting
bigger let go of the g20 nations the
countries were the biggest economies
account for more than three-quarters of
all emissions but just five including UK
have committed to all but eliminating
greenhouse gases China is increasing the
amount of energy it gets from coal
faster than the rest of the world is
consigning it to history horrible costly
one-sided Paris climate Accord in the
United States President Trump has signed
the papers to withdraw from the world
climate deal and in Brazil the
government has encouraged the Amazon to
be cleared to make way for economic
development the climate emergency is
here and now so it's happening to people
it's happening to wildlife so we're
seeing impacts on people already at one
degree we're seeing sea levels rise
we're seeing animals
to move from their home we're seeing
habitat destruction at the UN climate
summit in Madrid next week negotiators
from around the world will be under
pressure to cut emissions faster this
report warns delaying action by just one
year will make it even harder and more
expensive to stabilize the planet's
climate Thomas More Sky News